Now we move to our Southern border from
Texas to California it's estimated that
tens of thousands of migrants are
waiting for title 42 restrictions to end
so they could enter the U.S and seek
Asylum they will likely spend Christmas
waiting in the cold Omar via Franca has
the latest from El Paso Texas one city
struggling to handle the Overflow
in just the last week alone nearly 6 000
migrants have been shuttled through El
Paso to cities across the country to
process their immigration claims
but that still leaves thousands of
migrants in El Paso and with shelters
overcrowded city leaders opened the
convention center overnight it can house
more than one thousand migrants they
want to get as many people as possible
off the streets with temperatures
dropping below freezing this week
and now conditions are getting worse
with the potentially deadly coal snap on
the way yet the line to enter El Paso
does not end
up to a thousand people wait along the
fence Stephanie Rubio and her
two-year-old son traveled here from the
Dominican Republic
[Music]
was greeted with armed soldiers military
vehicles and razor wire all part of
Texas Republican Governor Greg Abbott's
operation Lone Star the people who were
crossing into El Paso should be
blockaded
who traveled all the way from Venezuela
for CBS mornings Omar via Franca in El
Paso Texas